- All right, we've got one last story.
I hope it's gonna make you smile.
This is What I'm Liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience applauding)
So, last year was a record
setting year for concerts.
No joke.
More tickets were sold last year
than in any year in history.
(audience clapping)
One thing we truly missed
was getting together and enjoying music.
Well, there's a charity
making sure veterans and their families
get to take in live shows all
for free, which is so cool.
It's called Vet Tix,
and we have the Chief
Strategy Officer, Steve,
on the line right now.
He also happens to be a veteran himself.
Thank you so much for your service, Steve.
(audience cheering)
I'm gonna lead with that.
And then also, I love this
idea. Where did this come from?
- Well, this idea came from
our founder, Mike Focareto.
He's a Navy veteran.
And back in 2008, he was at
the Super Bowl here in Phoenix,
and he looked around and
saw pockets of empty seats.
And he thought, "What a waste.
How can I get veterans and service members
and their families into
these seats that go unused,
not only at sporting events,
but at concerts as well?"
So, he created Vet Tix.
Fast forward 15 years,
and now we have over 2 million members
and we've distributed
over 15 million tickets.
(audience applauding)
And these tickets are donated
by performers, promoters, entertainers,
and Kelly, a lot of our Vet Tix members
have attended concerts
seeing you through Vet Tix.
- Oh my gosh! That's awesome.
So, this has a special meaning
for each person who gets
to go to a show, right?
- Absolutely. I spent 32
years in the Marine Corps.
I retired as a colonel.
And when you're in the military
or you're a first responder,
you miss time away from your family
and you miss a lot of events.
So, if we can use these tickets
to send these service
members and first responders
and their families to these
concerts and other events
as a way to make up for that
lost time and create memories,
then it's a great thing.
And you know, Kelly, music heals,
and it really helps create memories
and helps people through
the challenges and struggles
they've had in serving in the
military or their community.
The cool thing is,
is that these tickets are usually donated
in sections or blocks.
So, these members are at these events
with other service members
or first responders
as a way to make new friends,
create bonds and new memories.
- This is such a cool thing
that you've done for all these people.
Steve, thank you so much.
I'm liking your post right now, right?
(audience applauding)
And that's not all, Steve.
Our season long partner Pilot Pen,
makers of G2, the the go-to
pen of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to help you provide more veterans
with concert experiences,
so they're gonna give Vet
Tix a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(audience clapping)
- That's amazing.
Thank you so much, to you and to Pilot.
Because with that donation,
even more veterans and service members
are gonna create even more memories
than they've already experienced.
So, thank you so much.
- Aw, man, that's all because of you
and this domino effect that you started.
Thank you, Steve.
All right, thank you to everybody.
All our guests this hour,
Pink, Justin Derrico, and Tim.
Y'all have a great day.
And if it's not, just listen
to Pink. You'll feel better.
(audience clapping)